the war in ukraine is making ripples a
continent away in taiwan faced with the
ever-present threat of a chinese
invasion the island has raised its alert
level
that alert level was demonstrated
recently through a military exercise on
the island of dongyeon which is under
taiwan's control soldiers fired
anti-aircraft and machine guns in a
simulation exercise
now compared to the rest of taiwan
dengue lies just 16 kilometers from
china's fujo city
the constant threat of an invasion from
china has forced a reorganization of
taiwan's armed forces part of that has
been to try out doubling the training
time for taiwan's reserve force that
force is made up of the roughly 1.65
million young men who've served the
mandatory four months in the country's
military dw correspondent zachary lee
was at one such training event
received his call-up letter weeks ago
today huang is saying goodbye to his
friends before he begins two weeks in an
intensified military training program
locals are calling it the toughest
taiwan has ever seen
14 days is a bit too long it's like
basic training for military service and
it's kind of a waste of time it's also a
huge inconvenience for my employer but
since the russia ukraine war began i've
thought about a war between china and
taiwan what if china really attacks us
and with that in mind huang is joining
15 000 other reservists for the program
he'll spend ten hours a day on combat
training such as shooting weapons and no
days off
taiwan's president says taiwan cannot
let down its
the guard in ukraine has once again
proven that national security relies not
only on assistance from the
international community but also on a
unified citizenry this training is
undertaken not only to protect and
defend the nation but also to
consolidate a unified front
beijing views taiwan as a breakaway
province while the taiwanese have long
seen china as a threat the russian
invasion of ukraine has reignited these
concerns
some in the military worry about
taiwan's ability to fight off an attack
we don't want to see a situation like
the one in ukraine here so we must be
strong and perform well in each of our
roles we need to be able to refine our
skills this is the most important
purpose of the training program
russia's war against ukraine can be seen
as a wake-up call for taiwan people here
are already concerned about from china
and beijing has given tacit approval to
the russian invasion
doubling trending time for thousands of
free service is only the first step
further defensive moves are expected
earlier this year taiwan reported the
largest incursion of chinese air force
jets in months
experts here say it needs to improve its
security
99.7 of our goods are imported from
overseas
if the people's liberation army were to
block taiwan by cutting off shipping
lanes and operationalizing air sea
battle the threat is clear and urgent
taipei is worried that beijing could
take advantage of the ukraine crisis to
raise pressure on the island
huang and his fellow reservists hope
that doesn't happen
but they'll be ready if and when it does
i'm joined now by a kitsch leo yanfan
he's the military and cyber affairs
consultant for double think lab a civil
society organization in taiwan mr leah
welcome what lessons would you say is
taiwan drawing for its own security from
the invasion of ukraine
um well there are several um actually so
for example our most important one was
actually uh iterated by emerald lee
uh in an article just yesterday we're
talking about the importance of um
the importance of a motivated reserve
the uh concept of a territorial defense
force
uh and also you know the uh which
incorporate uh the earlier concept of
overall defense concepts
um what that means is that
a people is only as strong as its will
to fight
and it's important to utilize the window
over opportunity in a hybrid force
including a motivator reserve and a
conventional force in order to
inflict maximum amount of damage to the
invaders
what are some of the other uh changes
that need to happen in taiwan's military
strategy i'm glad you talked about the
territorial defense force the creation
of a territorial defense force and we've
already seen taiwan as for example
trying out a pilot program to increase
the amount of training for reservists
the existing reservists what does taiwan
need to be doing to make its defenses
strong
oh thank you
so in order to do this
first of all a winning media strategy is
a given as we've seen in ukraine um the
most important thing is to keep the um
the people's um sorry sorry it is
important to keep the people's morale
and also their training up so a winning
media strategy in order to communicate
in no definitive terms to the people um
that
we will fight till the end that is uh
that is of the paramount importance
and to that end
our coalition
uh especially defense
defense coalition planning with allies
is another important step in this
because unlike ukraine taiwan does not
share any land borders with any other
country
any help any assistance to taiwan
would have to come from overseas and
that that brings us to the importance of
another aspect
uh in taiwan's potential war which is
called the war reserve stop that has
been discussed before
which
basically talks about putting munitions
and other reserves in taiwan but not
under the control of taiwan
before the beginning of the conflict
uh i'd just like to talk about the
united states here i mean the united
states is the biggest armed supplier for
taiwan and is also bound to taiwan by
the taiwan relations act
how does the how do taiwanese military
planners factor in the united states in
any potential invasion scenario
thank you
well currently um taiwan
has its own plan to actually conduct its
own defense
without having a without having the
support from the u.s it is of course
welcomed and in the grand scheme of
things
uh a u.s
support
potentially be required
and this brings us to another very
important aspect
of the lessons learned from ukraine
which is coalition planning
right
as we can see from ukraine the
importance of
istar support intelligence surveillance
targeting and reconnaissance support is
of paranormal importance and this is
something your allies and coalitions
could provide to you without actually
uh sending troops and actually firing
weapons on the enemy for you
uh briefly um
i'm interrupting i just want to
wanted to sort of sum up what you were
saying briefly if you could tell us do
you think all this will be enough for
taiwan to defend itself against any
chinese attack
if you were done actually you know um to
a certain degree yes i believe this
would be enough however the vagaries of
war the pop of war means that we could
only do the best we can
and the the most important aspect of all
of this i would say is the will of the
people
clearly put there uh
from a double think lab a civil society
organization in taiwan thank you so much
sir for joining us today
thank you